i was like wait
okay
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
special guest on the channel you guys
requested her after last time i was told
we like her but we want to hear her talk
more so here you are
yes thank you for having me back i
appreciate it thank you for coming on
um so my name is jessica and you can
find me on instagram and youtube as it's
your girl jess on instagram after it's
in yeah there's a dot and after girl
there's an underscore and then jess on
youtube it's just it's your girl jess
yeah and you guys should go subscribe to
our youtube
youtube channel her videos are actually
really fun i watched a couple i'm gonna
be uploading some more here and there's
gonna be a little throwbacks that i have
from
past adventures that i've had so stay
tuned
so before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos
okay
so where are you from let's let's do a
little background on jess
so i was born in california and then i
was raised in michigan then once i got
old enough i moved back to california
okay i would say i'm a michigander
californian okay and how old are you i'm
27 years old
so
tell me your basketball history like
give me give me your stats
oh goodness stats
i'm just kidding no um so my basketball
history i started playing basketball
when i was in
fifth grade on
what did we call it like kind of like a
little league team i forgot the name of
it but i started then and then i
played all throughout high school all
throughout college and then i took a
break and then i am playing here in the
uk at school
so you played was it a division one
division two d3 school you played at so
when i started in college i played at a
juco or junior college
and i played one year in michigan out of
school in flint uh called mock community
college and then i played one year at
cypress college in california and then i
transferred to azusa pacific university
in
california and it's a d2 okay and did
you get to play a lot there
decent not as much as i would have liked
to play but you know when it comes to
school and coaches and politics they
have their own things yeah well i mean
it's kind of if you make it to that
level everyone's good yeah you know like
you can't really make it to a certain
level except a couple d3 schools you
guys know who you are
yes there's a couple that are really bad
in d3 at least but like for the most
part no one can really make it to that
level without being pretty good yeah and
i met jess because i like randomly
joined the basketball team at uel
so i'm i'm on the volleyball team here
and i like play with the basketball team
sometimes yeah when our games don't
overlap
and jess was like the best one on the
team by far
calm down come down
she's like they might see it
they would know
i wouldn't say i'm the best but i'm i'm
one of the she's one of the few she's
the best one of the few one of the few
um
but they also have like a pro team here
the london lions
which is like they're crazy good too
like the best basketball players i have
ever seen in my life they're so good and
to be able to play with some of them
that are on the university team and then
on london lions has been a pretty cool
experience to be like oh i've played
with pro players no big deal yeah oh my
gosh i'm i was like
i was like i'm so sorry i'm on the court
because you guys
like we play with this one girl who she
competed at division one in the top like
15 they made it to or top 20. um i think
so i think it was top 15 the school she
went to yeah that's cool yeah that's
that was crazy
um
so the reason i brought you here today
was on the last show you're on when i
said that men are better than women
you're mouth your like face was like
and i think later you kind of understood
a little more what i was saying yeah
but you're you re did you rewatch that
um i didn't see that part we watched a
little bit i didn't see that part i
probably did my little face i probably
was like
but do you do you agree with me that men
are better than women at least like
physically and at basketball generally
it's
it's sad it's tough because
it's
like
physically
men are just going to be better than
women physically because of just
genetically how they are and how they
feel
but
when it comes to
when it comes to some sports if you take
away the
genetic side of it and you go to the
skill side
it's
it's hard to say like oh
men are better than women if we're just
talking about skill set if we're talking
about genetics of course men are going
to be better than women because
it's just a given well i just think of
like height alone even if we take out
the strength component yeah so i'm i'm
six foot tall
so i'm in the top one percent of height
for females yeah if i if i was a male or
like if i had to compete in a male
division i would have no opportunity
because i i'm in the top 15 percent of
height like that's a very you don't you
know what i mean like i can't score
against a 610 guy i just can't i'm it's
difficult um it's doable
i've had to play against for some of
them
i better play against some girls that
are
like a lot of inches taller than me like
six foot six plus even my first game in
high school i
was a freshman
no i was a sophomore my first game in
varsity in high school i played against
this girl she was like 6-2 one of the
best in the league and my coach looked
at me and he was like are you ready i
was like yeah i went out there i got my
first double-double ever yeah so
i can understand what you're saying
about
height and differences in that sense and
it is going to be different it's going
to be a different playing field all
across the board but
i'm
not 100 like men are better than women
because there are some
this in areas that
women are better than men
which ones
well are we talking about sports or
talking about just both you can
because i really can't honestly think of
what athletically
athletically
like strength wise they're gonna win
speed wise they're gonna win height wise
they're gonna win i can't think of one
yeah it's
it comes down to like if you even even
if we do skill right yeah who's going to
win if you're faster and stronger
but is that is that skill
it goes into it
you're you're much faster than me that's
why you beat me all the time in
one-on-one
okay okay i can okay i can understand
that there then
in a sense there are
i'll say some men i won't say all men
but there are some men that are better
than women when it comes just
just naturally and in that skill set
yeah
i would agree with that okay
okay so no we pretty much agree on that
you just you just wouldn't so where do
you just i just don't understand like it
seems like when i say that general
statement you agree with me or you
disagree but then when i like get to the
nuts and bolts then you're like
then you agree yeah so
i
i won't say a hundred percent like i
agree with your statement like yes yeah
there are going to be men that are
better than women but i won't say oh 100
yes
right that's where i'm like
disagreeing okay so i think you're maybe
talking about
like clearly the girl that we play with
could be 90 of guys in one on one
and you probably could beat
90 percent of guys in one-on-one maybe
80. whatever it is a good a good person
i can too i've beaten guys in one-on-one
all the time
but i think it's like when we look at
like men as a whole and women as a whole
in general like men are going to be
better than women would you agree with
that
it kind of makes your stomach it's a
little bit yeah it's just like
it's just
hard to be like yeah
cause
i'm off for like beat the man be damn
let's go and we can show that we're
better yeah me too it's really fun to
beat guys in one-on-one i do it yeah
it's it is fun
and that's just where i like have some
reserve i'm like
so yeah
um okay so quick quick pause thank you
to the gray pill podcast hey miss
ponytail my favorite gal two dollar
super chat hey how you doing
[Laughter]
okay um oh someone this is a good
question so what skill sports-wise are
women better at than men in general can
you think of one or no
so there was something
that i saw and that i may be misquoting
it i saw a while ago
but um
it was something about shooting
percentages in the nba and wnba and they
showed that
some players had a better shooting
percentage than um
some players in the wnba had a better
shooting percentage than
the men in the envy in the nba and it
wasn't like
people coming off the bench and like oh
they're shooting percentage better than
that person but it was like people like
up there that people wouldn't know
um
that's the one thing i know off the top
of my head
do you so if i look up right now wnba
shooting percentage and nba shooting
percentage are you saying wnba is going
to be better
i don't know this the answer to this
question
it's okay it's hard because
there's so much that goes into
shooting percentages and what type of
shots are they taking what type of shots
right where are they taking i would
imagine the men it's harder because
they're going up against six ten yeah so
you would think that
yeah
it's i don't
i cannot answer that question fully to
where like oh there's specifically like
one sport where there's
women that are better than
men you know what we're just going to
set up a like a day to where everybody
competes men and women together and see
who's better than them
do you realize they've like done that
though
but serena williams the best tennis
player in the world
loses to the 200th tennis player in the
world men's wise hungover
he's hung and she admits it
when was that when they practice
together all the time oh okay
and like there's been instances where i
don't remember if it was high school or
college teams but they've beaten wnba
teams i know when you said that on the
last podcast i was like first ask that
out pull it up pull it up we don't know
where that's at we can
i've never uh um
i've never heard that so when you said i
was very shocked yeah it's i mean
because you think about it like guys
have people i've never met a girl that's
six ten
have you
and if she is she's super awkward like
and not
like i've i've seen men that are in
control of their bodies and they're like
above six five yeah every six five wnba
i don't think i've met a girl at six ten
um okay u.s women's basketball
team loses to college program
oh wait that's girls and girls
um wnba male practice squad loses to
women all the time
sure let me i'll find it okay and i'll
you just have to take my word but i
swear i'm not just making this up no i
know you wouldn't make up something um
okay let me look at i think someone sent
a super chat really quick
okay 20
super chat
mic money thank you so much
you guys know
the mic money coming in you guys know
how how hard i've been working on this
show so i really really appreciate all
the donations i'm not even keeping money
for myself right now all donations are
reinvested into the show
so all the money right now is going
towards a second sound board and another
set of mics okay
um
okay so then now this is going to
transition into the next
the next
topic so
transgender u-pen swimmer leah thomas
wins the 100-meter and 200-meter
freestyle races against harvard
days after usa swimming said it would
release new policy on whether elite
trans
athletes will be able to compete against
biological women
so what what is your take on that
i've had conversations like this with
multiple people and it's like
there's
in my opinion
there's like no like definitive answer
because it's
it's hard
to
say to someone like okay you identify as
a woman but no you're not and
it's
it's difficult because of just like i
was saying earlier genetics like i
someone could say i identify as woman
but physically your body
is not
identifying as woman because of just how
you were born and there's just
things that
contribute to you
being what you were before you transit
transits into a woman that
puts you head and shoulders over
women like we were saying earlier just
genetics
and so
it's
it's difficult to be like no you can't
do it i think it'd be really easy for me
to say no
would actually be like really easy
because here's here's my my my take on
it we work so hard yeah i have worked
like so incredibly hard to get to the
point where i am in like i'm i'm more of
a volleyball player right yeah so
to me
the idea of we have such a small pie
anyway is there money in women's sports
and i've worked so hard and i see the
contracts that are out there for girls
better than me
and they're not making anything and
they're way better than me
so
to me it's like disrespectful to women
to like take away the little opportunity
we have in sports
what do you what do you think about that
statement
uh
it is uh
you don't have to try it carefully no
it's it's just like
it's
this this topic it's just
difficult to have for me to have like a
like be like yes no because
i don't want to
disrespect anybody and their life and
how they uh well but it's not about what
they think it's about like what do you
like what's right what's fair
yeah and
i've said like well maybe they should um
in athletics put like a
number of how much testosterone you can
have in your system how much estrogen
you can have in your system but then
that would
count out the women who are born with
more testosterone naturally who are born
women and
it's
it's hard and it's it puts
in physical contact sports because i've
played against
a transgender woman and and i've had
friends who've played against
transgender women and it
puts us in like a
you've played it again oh that never
happened to me actually when my second
year of college i played against a
transgender woman and then i had a
friend this past actually last year she
was in a tuesday night basketball league
and she played against a transgender
woman and
physically it's like she was telling me
like why is this person like bulldozing
me over i'm not like a small person i
can
body someone on defense but this woman
that she was playing a plane against was
just knocking her over and she found out
that she was a trans woman and
it's
in a sense like sometimes dangerous in
contact sports to be playing against a
transgender woman because if you play
against
a man they're going to be just it's just
naturally like physical right because
right that's who they are and so
there's a different like physicality
when it comes from women to men and i
just think when it comes to physical
sports
it's a little bit more like
safety right so so
it's funny because
it sounds like you're saying it's not
fair
and you agree with me but it's almost
like there's a part of you that doesn't
want to admit it because you don't want
to like offend trans people it's not
that i don't want to offend it's like
i
because if we don't speak up for
ourselves like you will
yeah that is true like and that's what
we're seeing now like we can't speak up
for ourselves people are afraid to
offend that community because they're
very loud
but it like to me this is this is like
um the the transgender woman or woman
that like won that race that that is so
disrespectful to the women that worked
their whole lives
and you know how little opportunity like
like we get four years in college
everyone i know that's played says
college is the best four years you're
going to play yeah you get the community
like even coming overseas it's just not
it's it's do you think it's the same i
don't think it's this it's different it
really is different and even talking to
the girls that play pro they all like
told me
well the you know the one or two i asked
yeah
that they preferred college and and i've
talked to girls from my college everyone
says college and so that's a moment that
the girl that got second third whatever
they're never gonna get that back yeah
and
i just feel like if we as athletes can't
stand up for ourselves like who will
yeah that's true and
i can understand that because i would be
upset if i was
in a position to and i was in college in
a position to go play on a pro team
overseas and then
a transgender woman comes into the team
and they're out there dunking doing
everything bodying people and i'm like
i i physically can't do that right
limits like i physically i cannot do
that i can train i can train to where i
get hops and i can dunk and i can body
people but it's like i have to
physically train whether
and it's this person that has it because
they were born with it and so
it's
it's difficult because it's like i think
that there should be
more
caution when it comes to it
but i also don't want to be like
no like
like you can't
so if there was a law that came forward
and said it's biological men biological
women there's no in between would you be
against that
we're talking about politics now bro we
bring up things
it's not political it could be a college
like rule right yeah
uh
i i probably wouldn't be against it it
would suck because it would essentially
be taking away the opportunity for
whoever to be able to participate in the
way they identified
um
i don't know maybe for
in the future they have certain teams
that like are just like trans male or
trans women to where that
this like isn't a problem or in a sense
well i would be okay if you know there
was some league that was co-ed where
even in you know colleges or whatever
like certain amount of men's biological
men certain amount of biological women
so they can compete in something yeah
but i
i keep seeing these like trans
men competing in the women's division
and just
annihilating everybody yeah
and i i've never actually been in a
position where i played against somebody
but it boils my blood because i i've
worked so hard
to get to this point where i have
very little up like
i think if i got a pro contract i would
get free housing
and maybe 10 000 like for the whole nine
months okay that's that's like that's
not
something
i don't know how it is in basketball
because no clue but
the
um even the girls i was talking to
they're wit like
way better than me and they don't get
they maybe get 15. wow well i don't not
the i don't know the girls on the lions
like i didn't ask them the money but i
mean like the pro girls that i know yeah
um and it's just it's funny because i
feel like you agree with me but you just
really don't want to offend that
community it's not that i don't want to
offend them it's like for me i
i see where you're coming from and
i
i see both sides like i understand
their
side and understand your side it's just
like
i'm just in the middle it's like a happy
medium
so like i understand both sides but i
don't want to
take a side
not take a side by
it
i don't i don't know i just and not that
i don't want to take a side it's like i
understand both and i understand the
the value in both
it's like
okay so if there was a rule that they
said
trans women are allowed like they can
anyone can identify as trans and as long
as they're on estrogen for a year they
can play it doesn't matter if they're 6
10 it doesn't matter like anyone would
you
support that rule
i would i would probably be like upset
and frustrated
because of just what we've been talking
about
and so um
so no yeah no i probably wouldn't it'd
be
it'd be difficult like even if they
like did it i would so welcome that
person in but it would be
a little bit
like hard to be like um
and like i want to clarify i don't have
any problem like doing it with you know
what they do like with their bodies yeah
right yeah i'm horse i'm i'm nice you
know what i mean i'm a chit chatter yeah
i'm friendly
i won't remember most people's names but
i'll talk to them
[Laughter]
but um i just i think you know as
athletes we kind of have to have these
conversations
and
like it seems like most girls i talk to
agree with me but also don't you know
we're agreeable i think like most women
are more agreeable do you know what
agreeable means yeah yeah yeah than men
so i think we don't like the idea of
like excluding somebody
yeah i can understand that
definitely okay we got a ten dollar
super chat let's see thank you doug mpa
the trans debate is a way for white men
and women to take the conversation of
oppression away from
people of color the loudest trans groups
are trans white women 70
of non-binary people are white women
do you agree with that or disagree
i can't say yes or no on that i yeah i
don't know i don't know anything i don't
know a lot of trans women to say yes
i don't
i don't think i know anybody that's
i think i've met people that are trans
like in passing but i don't actually
like know anybody that's trans do you
uh
they're not trans but they're non-binary
they're not oh wait i do know somebody
non-binary
but
it's actually the girl that was jessica
she's non-binary oh okay but she doesn't
um
like
care if you say she okay so it's kind of
like like her um
her pronouns that's the word almost said
yeah like that's not the right word yeah
gonna look at some of the comments
i
i'd like to point out that cis women are
barred from competing in the olympics
because their testosterone
was too high
okay
i think that's all the
there was a um
a woman athlete that um i forgot where
she was a runner from i like literally
see her face in her uniform everything
was a
black athlete and
she
great
great runner
and she
i can't remember it was this last
olympics olympics before last but she
was she wasn't allowed to run because of
her testosterone level and
it's like something that she can't oh
she can't control yeah because she was
naturally born with just a higher
testosterone level
so
do you think do you think that trans
rights should be included in women's
rights
no
because
i think that they
are
like
i think it's different
there's different things that come with
being trans whether it's male or female
and
just how because if if we wanted to
clump everybody together
what was the point of separating men and
women's rights yeah so i think that they
should have
the trans rights
and
that should be something different do
you think that if we are going to
compete against trans women that
the everyone should be disclosed
beforehand that they're trans so we can
make a decision if we want to compete
um an example that i'm thinking of off
the top of my head is there was a girl
that
um
or a trans a trans woman that was
competing in boxing like and and they
they didn't disclose
that she was previously a male
boxy it was it was some sort of fighting
emma i don't i know there's like
different types of fighting i don't just
say
yeah and so and so like this trans woman
was like beating
the [ __ ] out of these girls
and they didn't even know until later it
came out
do you think that beforehand that [ __ ]
and i i would say
i would be pretty upset if i got hurt in
a basketball game because
i i play against guys all the time
and at my skill level usually when i go
to like a park or anything if they
played through high school i can compete
with them but usually if the guys made
it to college i can't yeah i can't keep
up
um that's kind of how i gauge it or if
they're really good in high school like
maybe i can't but
um
so there's certain games i don't play in
because i am like i've just you know
you've seen a court and i'm like i will
get my ass
yeah yeah yeah
i think that
it should for the safety of the other
team it should be disclosed
that this person is a
trans woman
and
it
it yeah it should just be disclosed
because you could look at somebody say
i'm not saying you are or look like one
but you are a trans woman and you came
to practice and i'm like oh pearl cool
right and you come on there and you
shoulder check me and i go flying i'm
like how the heck i'm like i'm the same
size as you how is she shoulder checking
me and sending me across the court and
then i realized like oh
she's a trans woman
okay that makes sense and i think it
would be if the situation was to happen
i think it would be for the safety of
both teams to be
disclosed like hey we do have a
transgender woman on our team actually i
have a
um a person that i coached with back in
the states that is playing with the
trans women on their team in a school in
orange county california i can't
remember the name of the school but
essentially it's an undergrad
degree that she's getting and she's a
trans woman playing
so
like that that makes my blood boil that
makes my blood i think that that is so
disrespectful to the women like i think
i i'm so passionate about women's sports
like i
i don't know maybe it might not sound
like it because i don't um it sounds
like you know because i don't you know
i'll say men are better than women but i
just think
like we we work so hard to do these like
extraordinary things like really really
great
you know like high shooting per se like
we're we have progressed so much in the
last 50 years when it comes to athletics
i would be a different person today if i
didn't have athlete like you know like
it's your whole life literally and it's
so fun and i love it and i hate
competing against guys
i hate playing basketball guys one
they throw the shot up the first three
they get
they never pass
and especially if you're playing against
them from my experience yes
they want to
showboat they want to
exert their masculinity onto you and
it's just like
we're just playing basketball not the
nba calm down
so that's
yeah
i understand
or a lot of sometimes i feel like they
do outside shots because they feel bad
bodying me yeah that too it's just like
i could go on all day about playing with
dudes and basketball it's just
yeah yeah
but it's interesting because you're
older than me and when i was in college
i never played against a trans woman so
it's interesting that you did but maybe
it's because you were in california
uh probably if i was in michigan
i probably wouldn't have yeah california
and she was older too and it was an
undergrad uh not undergrad it was a juco
college so
she was
i want to say she was in her
late 20s early 30s she was like yeah a
lot older than all of us and
taller
way taller
yeah i mean
top 15 yeah so um
kind of going back to the men versus
women okay so let's let's talk about the
army standards
okay they um in the army they have
i don't know if they still do but i know
at one point they had a different set of
standards for men and women okay um to
like compete at a certain level
okay so or not sorry competes and that's
the army but
[Music]
but like make it to a certain level is
you know one fitness test for men and
one for women
i think that's wrong okay because i
think it should in the army if they're
competing for the same job they should
have the same standards
would you agree with that
for
a job standpoint or for the fitness test
for okay so
if in the army they're trying to be
i don't i don't know army stuff so
something where they're trained to like
carry a person out
you know and like whatever whatever you
do physically like navy seal maybe i
don't know i don't know okay i don't
know army stuff
but but i'm saying like if they're if
they're training to do the same exact
job
i don't think there should be a set of
standards for men and for women it
should just be one standard
because
um i think women should be excluded if
they can't meet the same standards that
men meet and if that results in a low
percentage of women joining that job so
be it i don't think 50 50 is the answer
i think that results in women that
aren't qualified getting jobs they don't
deserve okay
okay so
earlier you had said that
um
men are faster men are taller men are
stronger
so in a
physical test
why would
if men are better in this area
why would women be held to that
standard if essentially they're already
coming in
lower than the men well because it's the
same job
okay so i would say if
i really wish i could use i'm gonna just
look in the chat real quick and see if
there's
uh a job i can use because i don't know
army stuff
um
okay no one put it in the chat
but
sean turner said there is no compete for
a job in the military
no
biological women they tried they tried
it they ended up yeah i'm pretty sure
they changed it but at one point it was
um like say you're competing for a
certain ranking like to to become
this position in the military right
you have to be this standard like like
this amount of push-ups this amount of
whatever does that make sense yeah yeah
um and you're going to be when you're
working in that job you're doing the
same thing the men and the women are
doing the same thing
but
with the men's fitness test
um
it's it's too hard for most women like
most women aren't going to pass it
resulting in a smaller percentage of
women doing that job
i think that's okay
would you say that they should then
switch the test and make it easier for
women
so it can be closer to 50 50 doing that
job
no i would say no
because
if
if you make it the same standard then
it's like they're already coming in
at a
as like an underdog in a sense trying to
make up something that they
physically
do not have to try to meet the
the same standards as someone that's
already head and shoulders above them
and so in that sense
what would be the point of
women trying to join the military unless
they were able to
meet that so we should
then say hey so you can so you would
want different standards yeah i think
that there should be different standards
because even i don't know if you had it
in high school the um
fitness stuff yeah there's different
standards for um
boys and girls but in high school you're
not competing for a job
you're not you're not so
like the reason there's different tests
is because men and women are different
biologically but in this they're doing
the same job
when
so so for example they would have to
maybe and i think someone used firemen
as an example okay you know they like
you know being a fireman you have to
carry people and be strong enough to do
that but
like if women aren't strong enough to do
the job i don't think we should give
them a special handicap
saying oh just because
you guys are weaker let me lower the
standards for the job for you like
if you're not qualified you're not
qualified yeah i don't i don't know what
the standards are but right i would hope
they wouldn't lower it so much and
somebody correct me if i'm wrong lower
it so much to where it's like
any joe schmoe
off the street can compete can do the
women's standards in the military and
pass it i would
hope that it would be a standard to
where
it would be like in a fireman situation
you would have to be able to carry
the weight of the suit everything on you
and then carry a person that's
minimum well say say that's the standard
right that that's the standard right
there just being able to yeah that's it
and they then women still can't make it
and like that results in a very small
percentage of women competing for that
like like being in that job
do you think that's okay then
because a lot of times like especially
today that we look for equality of
results yeah
and it it's like it's almost does a
disservice to people doing that because
then women are they're in a job they're
not qualified for so how are they going
to do it well when they're not strong
enough to be there yeah
so how does that like how does that help
us when they could pick a job like women
are better when we work with people we
tend to excel in fields with people
better than men
because i can
like we pick up on things that men don't
see so you know that dirty look we see
at the bar
men don't see that yeah like what are
you guys saying they don't they won't do
that but dude i'm saying like like if we
keep the standards the same
then
at least people end up where they're
supposed to end up maybe that's not the
right job for you
i i understand where you're coming from
yeah um with the standards but i do
think that are
that
there are women
we're speaking strictly military there
are women that are strong enough to do
the job but not to the standard of a
male okay and in that sense it's like
how can you hold someone to a standard
that
they
physically are not
at all and
they would have to
train i don't know how much longer to
get to that to where this person these
this group of people already gone so you
would want like special requirements for
women then
i would say that there needs to be
separate standards for men so then i
have a follow-up question to this
do you think that
it's wrong that
women
make more money in sex work and only
fans
how did we get it i don't know i'll tell
you there's no there's a there's a link
um
do i think it's wrong that women yeah
like they make way more
and do you think then that we should
rally for men to get paid the same
and be able to do that job
the same way that right now you're
rallying for women to be able to
excel right in those jobs do you think
we should do the same thing for men
okay so
i think i'll answer the first one um
i think the reason why women make more
money in the sex industry is because
that's just
how it's been for years and
how
just how society has had it in my
opinion yeah
but to take what we were talking about
earlier with the military and the
training and the standards well yeah but
that's how it's been for men for years
yeah but it's
like there's a training that goes into
the military well we could do we could
do haircut we could do a million i'm
using sex work because it's the most
prompt like i would say that's the
easiest
but we could we could use a different
industry
like we could use you know
modeling
you know that's without the okay
so okay like what i'm trying to get at
is i want to know do you feel the same
thing when men are not
able to compete like when women have an
advantage over men
do you are you gonna rally for men in
the same way
it's as different
between
the two examples that you gave are
different in my opinion because one is
you're training for something other one
sex work isn't real work no no no no i
didn't say that at all i said one year
training for it other one
essentially
and my knowledge because my knowledge
you don't need as
much training okay and
here you're trying to
essentially protect someone's life okay
and here
so you would think it'd even be more
important in this one that the standards
are the same
you're trying to protect someone's life
but if the standards aren't
significantly significantly lower like
if it was just like oh just do two
push-ups run a mile in ten minutes then
that would be like how it's how is this
person gonna protect me when i can run a
mile right in like six minutes and i can
do more push-ups and then
the standards i don't think that they
should be the same but i think that they
shouldn't be significantly less than
a male
but in areas where
areas where men make less than women
i'm like cool i'll keep it that way okay
so and you're
respectfully yeah you you only want
equality when it benefits women and not
men
that's that's what
[Music]
it's
it's
hard to say i don't want equality with
men because it's not that they could we
could do bars they let women in for free
and not men see i don't understand that
that that's that's where i don't
understand
money i
i have brothers and like when i go out
with my older brother i'm like why he
got to pay like let's just go in and so
there's just
certain
certain areas where men are going to
make more than women
women are going to make more than men i
think in
the two examples that you gave that
in the sex industry
women are going to make more than men
because who
for my knowledge who is the highest
consumer of the sex industry
and so insults
yeah
and this
in this area
is more
in the military example you gave
it's
it needs to be
similar but i still think there needs to
be a difference because of just
genetically and this the standard that
men have and then
trying to meet that standard when like
mm-hmm physically but i'm saying like
okay we could do a different industry
where there's more training required but
like the beauty industry mm-hmm
influencers yeah
that too beauty industry i think is just
basically what i'm asking is is your
answer going to change if maybe it's a
different type of job where women excel
more than men like i think women
make more money
being like the i think there's more
women in colleges now
so should we lower the standards for men
so they can get in like now because i
think it's 60 women to 40 men
or maybe maybe even more i think it
could be 70 30 too
so men are dropping out of colleges
right now okay
now should we lower those standards so
we can get men in that's because that's
you know something where you're training
to be in the workforce yeah
i'm just i just want to understand if
this is like because of the training or
if because you only
you only want this when it benefits like
women and not men
no so
i think that when it comes to physical
stuff i'm like there has to be some
because we're a disadvantage yeah
physically when it comes to that has to
be like a separation um
when it comes to other stuff
in situations where it's been like
male dominated
it's like uh
okay women are on the come up like cool
that's great like yeah
i like that
but
when you said in schools like
the attendance is it's 60 someone just
put in the chat 65 female
wow really yeah men are dropping out of
colleges why
why is that like what's the
you know the reason why
um i would say
that
um as you know i'm a conservative so i
would say it's because the schools
want well one the roi in college is
going down okay so
i think that more and more people are
not seeing the value in college um
and two i would say because colleges are
so like warped in like feminism these
days
that's this is that's a whole different
topic i'm not gonna go into no you're
good
but um i i don't think like education
favors men and
um
yeah that's just my opinion on it i
think it very much favors women
i've never
the reason why i'm like looking up and
like thinking
i've never heard
that about education yeah um
i would say in a sense not
lower
the standards because they can
they can get into college it's just
keeping them there and like bringing
more interest and
bringing more
things to interest meant to go to
college right now they're like well i
don't need to go to college i can go to
trade school i can go do this yeah yeah
so
okay so but you would not
so if we did a different job different
like you would
there are there any instances where you
would give men a handicap so to speak in
the same way you would give women a
handicapped
um
i can't think of any situations because
it's either
the wherever it is has been male
dominant
and now women are on the come up or it's
in the industry where it's female
dominant and now like men are starting
to join and men are on the come up and
so either way out i'm off for people's
come ups so i'm all for the come up
okay i'm going to look for super chats
because i know that chad is going i
warned you this was a controversial
episode before yeah
um let's see the
stop the cap if you came to the hood
they would space spanking both of you in
basketball one
i'm sitting i i played basketball on the
hood i know you guys would be shocked
i played i played with
from the top of the type of person to
the bottom of the top of person in
basketball
no cap here no camp here in the hood
there's
like when i the parks and milwaukee that
were like more sketchy
i
find people that play against like on
something sometimes so like
sometimes
yeah
um okay guys guys send money
send money
um
but i think
i think that's pretty much
it it's about eight o'clock i wanted to
do about an hour
um i appreciate you coming on a lot of
people would not be down to like have
these conversations i have these type of
conversations with people
all the time so i was like
do you feel like you look at anything
differently today after this
conversation or would you say your
opinions are pretty much the same
um i would definitely
look into like how is
because
all my not all my knowledge but like how
is it in just like society now that we
have so many different things going on
in the world so many different job
opportunities how is it now with
male and
female is
this area more female dominant is this
area more meltdown and why because i'm
always i'm always looking at things and
i'm like well why isn't there a female
version of this or why isn't there a
male version of this to like
bring like
so everybody gets to shot yeah
yeah
do you
think that
um do you ever wonder why women don't
want to be garbage men and plumbers like
why don't women i don't know
when i was older like as i grew up i
found out they make bang
i'll be in there with a plumber's crack
and i'll be throwing that trash on the
trash
on the of the truck
because um we always hear about like
women not being in positions of power
but my dad's he's like a top in terms of
earning potent like in terms of how much
he earns like top half a percent of like
income and i don't say that to brag but
i don't think most people and especially
women would want to do what he does
because he worked 80 hours a week my
whole life i wouldn't want to work 80
hours a week yeah i wouldn't either and
i think that's you know
partially i think women value
relationships more than men and my dad
has no friends
sorry dad
um jan 20 dkk lovely debate thanks dan
um it wasn't a debate mormon okay guys
whatever
okay guys um do you want to plug your
youtube instagram before we end it oh
i'll play one more time um it's it's
your girl jess on ig and instagram on ig
it's dot ya girl underscore jess on
youtube it's just it's your girl jess
okay guys do not forget to subscribe to
the ch
series out here talking she wanted to
say something okay guys um do not forget
to subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification
bell thank you so much for the super
chats today um there's another show
tonight at an hour and a half at 9 30.
it's going to be a little bit more
light-hearted more fun